- Early '70s when we were
down to 11.1 poverty,
which is the lowest we ever were
is that the good jobs went away
and we de-industrialized as a country.
That's the heart of it.
And most people who were poor,
except people who have disabilities,
they do have some income from work.
They're not some kind of
lazy something or other.
So the economy changed, the
structure of the economy changed
in a very, very fundamental way,
and then you add to it the fact
that you have mass incarceration.
You add to it what's happened to the cost,
on the other side, the
cost of housing, that.
There's a whole list of
things that have happened.
The changes in family structure.
You know, you can have
a big argument about,
you know, should people
get married, people that
dadadadada, you know.
That's a whole argument to have.
But bottom line, if you
have in a low wage economy,
that there's only one wage earner
who happens to be the mom,
then you have a very,
very serious problem.
And along with everything that I've said,
and there's more to say,
what's happened to our schools
in a time where we need much more capacity
to work on rather technical things
compared to working in a
steel plant back in the 1950s.
So all of this has changed,
and that's the reason
why with good public
policy, but not good enough,
we still have 43 million
people who are poor.